[Narrator] Here's our first programming
exercise.
I'd like you to make a robot that starts
at coordinates 30 and 50,
and it heads north, which means its
heading direction is pi/2.
It then turns clockwise by pi/2, which
means you subtract pi/2 from the
heading direction, and it moves 15 meters.
It then senses, and I want you to print
out the sensor measurements.
It then turns clockwise by pi/2 again,
and moves 10 meters this time
and I just want you to print out the
sensor measurements after this entire
procedure. So, there are 2 print
statements for the sensor over here
and the sensor measurements over here. So,
here's the output I would like your
program to generate.
After the first motion, the first
measurements will be 39 plus something,
46, 39, and 46.
And then after the second motion I expect
to see 32, 53, 47, 40.
Of course, there's lots of decimal-point
numbers over here,
but these are the numbers I would expect
you to output.
So, have fun coding it!